I think we should give him [ __ ] for not
being here at 12 45. he's here I I know
but he's gonna call it doesn't matter if
you're here we start at 12 45.
[Laughter]
but you know what we're rolling right
when you say what time you're starting
that is what time you're starting it is
12
42.3 minutes nobody warned him he's here
though he was here before you guys the
doctor is here you have a doctor the
doctor doctor's in but I know he's in
because
late though like have you I mean by the
way people are on Doctor time you know
what I mean doctors aren't on our time
we're on their time because we need them
to save our lives oh okay I think that's
fair if we I don't know we do but but
that's assuming he's on the phone right
now with a patient he could be on 90
because he always a bookie he could be
all in this bookie he could be on this
book he like be on with his mistress
sure he it could be uh his insurance
adjuster I don't know 90 patient
spending so uh a lot of time around Dr
Kipper he's Danny's doctor and he's my
doctor and uh and I consider him a
personal friend but the man's phone is
constantly ringing with oh while you're
in the room with him he's good about
like having it off but every now and
then he's like oh this is like uh you
know the the Sultan of Dubai and I have
to go take this and sure make sure his
cough is clear I've always appreciated
that about Dr Kimber I too have known
him for a very long time I made that up
about the Salton River so please
get off me he gives his patients access
sure well now and that's great
support but if you don't need this I can
remove this part for you I need
different support but he needs emotional
support emotional support okay I'll take
his lumbar support then if he's not okay
he's gonna double up sure but that's
just I don't have one oh I don't have
one okay I was just telling a story I
was down my wife and I were down in San
Diego having dinner at a restaurant
called market and I was talking to Chef
and I asked him if he had a good doctor
down in San Diego because we may be uh
moving there soon and he said yes I do
in fact uh his name is Dr Kipper now
would that be your brother I have two
brothers that are doctors down there so
it should have been my it would have
been my younger brother Stewart yes okay
he didn't mention the first name but he
said Kipper I was like that's crazy I'm
literally about to see Dr Kipper La Dr
kitten that's my little brother you have
how many brothers I have two brothers
and they're both doctors both doctors
was your was your father a doctor his
wife my father was a meat man a meat man
yeah is that just an older word for a
doctor a meat man the original doctor
that's right you know but I I love my
brothers and he's real he's great
um and is he you're an internist I'm an
internist okay and are they internists
this was an internist my older brother
is a nuclear medicine specialist so he
does all these crazy scans and I don't
know what he's Imaging studies and
nuclear medicine he does someone has a
heart problem development cancer problem
and they need Imaging scans and that's
what he does okay what does that have to
do with nuclear stuff though well they
use nuclear Isotopes is that right yeah
is that a new thing
yeah it is a new thing in those 60s I
think but it's it's relatively new okay
all right I was not familiar uh now of
all your siblings who has the most
famous patients this guy right you said
can't talk about it okay that's the best
that's the same names I mean we know
practicing out of Beverly Hills the
brothers are in San Diego well we can
talk about your question one who's not
here and and thank you for keeping them
alive so that he can do our show was he
not invited he's been invited many jobs
yes you know Danny he he's uh he's
elusive he's elusive he's elusive you
gotta you gotta grab him when he's
around you gotta get him roll out the
red carpet maybe I bet he's not elusive
for Dr Kipper no he's not we'll break
out some limoncello and we'll get I'm
I'm good thank you okay so are we good
question is are we good no so here's the
thing yeah how can we set this up okay
let's set it up like I want to ask a
bunch of questions before we even get in
I I think we I think that's let's give
him some context for how we we got into
this yes please how did we get into this
we decided Well no it was it was because
the episode sweetie uh has a heart
attack is coming up right we did an
episode where one of the characters has
a heart attack she goes to the hospital
and then she gets kicked out because she
doesn't have insurance and she can't pay
um but we thought like oh this would be
a good opportunity to find out if any of
us are headed towards heart attack
country and uh you know get our numbers
you know what I mean get our blood taken
and find out what's going on inside of
our bodies and and but most importantly
to find out who's the healthiest amongst
the three of us so it's it's US versus
each other this is very much a
competition so there's four of us
because Meg is awesome oh I'm sorry
that's right that's right I forgot you
got your your stuff taken too yeah so so
we are this is a competition
um and I'm just just hoping that you're
not biased towards Charlie because he's
your patient right well I'll tell you
this uh I feel in some ways I feel like
I lost already because I don't know
about you guys but after we sent in our
blood work I got a call from the company
which is okay okay never a good feeling
yeah what do you mean the company the
company that's testing the blood saying
hey what's diagnostic yes we are
required to call you and tell you about
this result in your blood oh wow okay
now so what was which what was that
um you okay man I'm a goner it's been
good to know you guys uh no it was a
cholesterol thing uh-huh but we'll see
what the numbers actually mean because
uh I think wait that's gonna do did you
then call Dr Kipper I think I think it
might be comparison yes I was about to
get upset with you because that ruins
the whole book of course no no no I was
just I and by the way we we did not
discuss but I was like hey just so you
know I got a call from this company and
they said would you like to consult with
our doctor I said no I have my own my
own doctor and he can tell me I'm dying
so um so you know maybe we'll cut all
this so it can be revealed but uh no I
got some numbers that were out of the
range according to them but maybe not
according to this guy we'll see well
here's what I do know in the beginning
now it's going to be us versus each
other but at a certain point I think um
if you give us all equally uh bad
information it's going to be us versus
you
um and really we'll be attacking you
personally attacking Western medicine in
general since I'm interpreting this
guess who's going to win
so Madison probably science I believe
according to the Hippocratic Oath you
can't oh you can't do harm you can't do
harm we can do emotional harm certainly
I don't think we would try to come at
you physically I don't think
you can do whatever you want that's true
they're not bound by those same you know
that's true this isn't even a union
can I propose a I don't know what your
format is it it's chaos
together
[Music]
so there's four four people that have
all these numbers and if it is a
competition we can certainly go oh Point
by point and say Rob wins this one Glenn
wins this one yeah
yeah so a point a point for each
category whoever wins each category kind
of a thing yes could there also be like
oh these are close
there could be that there could be a tie
for the two best there could be there
could be a very bad number for who does
the worst
um I don't know if we subtract from the
total I like it I like it I like rating
on scale all we are we taking age into
account or is it just overall health
because these guys are significantly
older
and we've got a few years on Meg but if
we're saying overall health I don't
think it should be relative to it
doesn't matter okay we are who we are
okay so however you want to do that I
mean I'm happy I like your proposal
let's go line by figure this out as we
go just like we have been doing the
podcast yeah and so do you would you
guys like a copy of everybody's results
or should you want to be surprised let's
be surprised okay can we before we do
this too can we all take a guess as to
who like what places we're going to come
in okay I'm going to guess that Rob is
the healthiest
followed by Megan sorry followed by
Glenn followed by me interesting I think
just based on lifestyle Choice yeah I
your lifestyle Choice I'm wondering if
things are too extreme too extreme too
extreme and it's tipped yes yes yes I do
agree that I think Glenn is is going to
be I think Glenn's going to come in
second or third though I don't like but
well he had me at third right you had me
in third place you had me a third I
think it's between Megan and Charlie now
but the cholesterol is very loud that
threw me a little bit Yeah Meg's pretty
healthy
I looked at my numbers already I looked
at my results I looked at my results and
they they lined up exactly with what I
assumed they okay we're gonna be because
I just had blood work done like three
months ago and it's almost exactly the
same right but I didn't change my nobody
changed their
routines or anything not like that right
I did exactly what exactly yeah there
was one issue and that was generic to
everybody is your blood pressures are
all in a dangerous Zone
this is a high stress job Gipper there's
a lot of you know I I was I think there
was something wrong with that machine
did they do it here or did they do it
here they did it here on the rest yeah
and it was uh I know that speaking for
myself I I was not I hadn't eaten
anything and I was like on like a lot of
coffee and we also had that effect all
just had our blood drawn right yeah I I
can tell you this I've never had high
blood pressure in your entire life yeah
well I wouldn't say never fair enough
according to the one according to this
yes so I actually brought a blood
pressure cuff so we could either just
knock this metric out and not bother
with checking your pressure lose the
blood pressure first or last as like a
tiebreaker yeah okay
although I feel like our blood pressure
might be rising
Under Pressure I'm learning a lot about
ties from your TV show wrexham yes which
is very good I said thank you nice I
watched it I was excited interested also
like what you thought of um
um I want you back I love it yeah we've
talked about it I loved it
I told you how much I loved it I we were
playing golf I can take you back to
Lakeside Golf Club this is a problem I
can't talk [ __ ] because I don't remember
stuff yeah I texted you right after I
saw it I enjoyed it thank you very much
I found it anyway we have Kipper here
let's not waste his time let's talk
about who's healthiest what's the first
metric yes so the first metric will save
the blood pressure for the end right
okay good I'm not so sure there's going
to actually be a tie that has to be
um does coffee affect it wow does coffee
affect the blood pressure it makes it go
up a little bit okay but I've had
nothing but coffee none of you are on
the lower side so it's you know I
wouldn't add more caffeine I've had a
tremendous amount of coffee Five Hour
Energy drink before okay all right so at
least we're all in the same so that's my
kidneys my liver and my heart yeah yeah
yeah that's right so let's do these one
at a time and I'll sort of grade them as
we go along and keep us tally here okay
this is amazing I'm so excited I've been
talking about this for a month right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you just made her dream come true look
at that it's a thousand times more
prepared coming into this podcast than
uh any of us have ever been I know
because he's a grown adult whose
responsibility yeah he assumes there's
structure and he thought
no he doesn't
[Laughter]
um all right so the first thing that
they measured was your BMI that's your
basic metabolic rate it basically it
tells you how overweight you might be
and you all did very well the there was
a tie it was a three-way tie between Rob
Glenn and Megan Sorry Charlie oh yeah I
know you weren't far behind but so you
could put in three wins there all right
so that's three points for you guys and
I I lose the point do I need okay
don't get a point no you're bmi's by the
way they were all good they were all in
a very good range okay
I have a little more power is what
you're saying
a little bit more mass if you could
cultivate that mass yeah yeah now if I
was their height when my my body mass
would be very good again there's you're
sort of lost that one
this is a two-way tie uh for Glenn and
Megan wait
wait you lost
you lost dollars now what's yeah what
does that mean because you're not saying
we win because we're the tallest right
you know that longevity data shows that
if you're very tall you have a shorter
life okay so that's the time for me
shorter lifespan got it I would vote to
strike that from the record because it
doesn't really make any sense I would
also like to strike weight because I
didn't enjoy that I was heavier than
most of the guys so if we could strike
that one
you are the only one pound but muscle is
heavy and you have a lot of muscle just
so you're walking around with a lot of
muscle I saw your Instagram post today
where you were pushing all kinds of
waves that also extremely muscular and
it's hard to yeah just go around by the
way I would if I were you pushed not to
have that metric stricken from the
contest the height one finally coming in
here I know yeah so I finally got a
point what point for shortness
okay so if Danny
given Charlie a point and I've also put
an asterisk next to it yeah I'm sure
there's gonna be tons of those I feel
like I would deserve the point more if
my body mass was his life as yours but I
think Glenn gets a point just out of
kindness because
the context of this is
the genetics yeah so all of these things
have to be interpreted in context so you
brought up genetics I think that's worth
happening yeah yeah just for for social
Consciousness for that I don't know too
much stress over here I I I appreciate
that uh I don't think I should get a
point for it simply because I think we
should just be getting points let's do
the hard number Stuff the hard numbers
now cholesterol we'll move into the the
fats and the lipids the lowest number
was Glenn
but and that was your total that was
total cholesterol but where there are uh
where the genetics come into play that's
where this one comes into play because
cholesterol is a genetically determined
metric
so
it does matter how much you eat and what
you eat to some degree but your basic
numbers are genetically predetermined
wow and when we relate this to heart
disease the genetics also take over
because if you have a family history a
strong family history for heart disease
your cholesterol has become that much
more important
especially if you have a first degree
relative that died early from a heart
attack like in their 50s then these
numbers become much more relevant so so
not everybody in these things but yes
because we have in my family we have
high historically high cholesterol but
my internist tells me that it's not as
big of an issue because we live into our
90s and nobody dies of heart disease
they all die of prostate cancer and
things like so a way to a way to
actually understand that is to do a
really simple test it's a calcium study
of your coronary arteries it's a six
minute test you don't get naked you
don't get stuck with a needle you're
laying on a table and it measures the
calcium in the in the three arteries of
the heart and if we see calcium in these
arteries it means that you're forming
plaque if you start to form a plaque a
cholesterol plaque if it lodges in the
artery it takes about 18 months for that
plaque to scar down and become calcified
so if we see calcium on this scan we
then understand that you are putting
some plaque into the arteries so let's
say you are you have a high cholesterol
but you have no plaque you have no
calcium then that's a genetic
cholesterol issue and you're really not
obligated to treat that so it's getting
that test the the total cholesterol is
meaningless it's the bad cholesterol so
it's the component well the total does
matter because if it's really high years
none of yours were really that high no
points wait a second now but that
doesn't matter he didn't say doesn't
matter at all he said it doesn't
should I get a point for it well you're
about to get a point for what I'm about
to explain maybe I get so there's
there's two kinds of cholesterol there's
a good and a bad and the good
cholesterol is good because it grabs the
bad cholesterol puts it into the Poop
Shoot and it eliminates it the bad
cholesterol is the one that lodges in
the arteries so you want a high HDL
right you want a low LDL right and the
LDL numbers are interesting because as
you pointed out we're learning more and
more about how these molecules work
we used to treat a an LDL with statin
drugs and there was a coronary
Association we would get those numbers
below 130 when I started practice and
that number dropped to 100 that number
then dropped to 70 and now it's 50. it
took a lot of people that had serious
heart disease bypass operations multiple
heart attacks they gave them these lipid
lowering medicines these statins they
followed these people and they followed
their ldls and what they found was that
the people that had these low ldls did
better so yeah what are our numbers
Glenn your number was you won you were
73 and Rob you were 137
Megan you were 83 and Charlie you were
110. so when they told you that your
cholesterol was up it's really a
meaningless that's what they remember
but that's what they were they're
referring to the LDL or is it the LDL in
relation to the HDL so if your HDL is
higher
does that cancel out some of the LDL yes
people that have a high HDL for whatever
reasons they have better longevity
statistics so they're somehow
eliminating the bad cholesterol and for
reasons that I've never understood they
seem to do better you can't do much to
raise your HDL that's sort of the
problem that's also a genetics so when I
got a call I think about the HDL right
which was hi you got a call about the
total cholesterol but your your HDL
actually all of you did really well with
your hdls your HDL was 67.
um robs was 70. Glenn 58 and Megan you
won this one you were at 88. hail
because you want to be higher there this
is how I've chosen to score this I'm
going to give Glenn a point for his
total cholesterol I put an asterisk
there because it's meaningless I've
given Glenn a point for getting the
lowest LDL and I've given myself a point
for having the best HDL okay that seems
fair that means the current health Point
score is Rob one Charlie one Glenn 3 and
Meg with two the other fat in the system
is the triglyceride and the triglyceride
is just another form of fat
we don't associate this necessarily with
heart disease but as you pointed out uh
Glenn there are there are studies now
showing that a high triglyceride May in
fact impact your uh problems with your
coronary arteries so having said that
the winning number here Megan at 45.
um Glenn you were 83 Rob 112 and Sorry
Charlie you were 136 but those are all
normal numbers so all within normal
range yes none of those are bad well so
so like mine is going to happen to be
more normal well so that's to say in
your opinion then does does it if we're
all within normal range does it is it
still significant I mean hers was though
significantly lower however I will say
than even mine uh she's at what 50
something hours 83.
um Megan's at 45. if I had 45 sorry pick
the blood I would want I would want the
45.
that answers the question it this is
also genetically determined and it's
hard to really change that but if you're
massively overweight and you're eating
all the wrong stuff you certainly can
raise your triglycerides that's actually
a good metric too the blood that you
would want or the number that you would
want no I think that's really good 100
totally because if it's all normal and
it doesn't really matter then this
doesn't work we need to find a way to
work yes
me being a lady doesn't have anything to
do with that right oh that's a good
question very good question no no okay
um yeah are there any advantages or
disadvantages that any one of us will
have for being either male or female
socially
yeah I would go ahead and knock a few
points off just for being a woman in the
society although she does live longer
she doesn't live as well it does but we
control whether or not exactly
her testosterons are going to be the
lowest right for PSA will be the lowest
right and your estrogens will be the
lowest right okay so it sort of washes
out okay great this is a point where you
want to pick your parents this is about
picking your parents with the heart
stuff and the fats so there's a measure
called a CRP a C-reactive protein and
it's a generalized
inflammatory marker and that
inflammatory marker indicates that
there's something going on in your
system so people that have arthritis
people that have cancer people that are
overweight that CRP number goes up and
the more inflammation there is the more
likely you are to mutate your cells and
get cancer and
heart disease is also
more vulnerable so on that
we have a three-way tie for the best
number which would be sorry Charlie
would be Rob Glenn and Megan you're
going to be so sorry you asked me I know
I I I predicted to be myself to be the
loser
your number was also normal so I met a
lot of pain and I feel very ill
you guys were very normal and you were
normal so so now have
three of us get a point yeah and then he
just does not get a point is that how
we're doing it okay
um sorry I didn't mean that to rub that
in I just wanted to no it's fine
whatever you get that number just goes
up just because your metabolism changes
people gain weight as they get older but
that's good that we're all within normal
range though can we acknowledge that
Charlie that you are within yes you know
healthy normal range that's not US
Health
that's true I want to get like a general
analysis and assessment at the very end
which is recognizing how old we are are
we healthy or not yeah I just would like
to know you know am I healthy in general
at the end of this but also like am I
also healthy for my age like because am
I walking out of here with a
prescription for Lipitor maybe but maybe
am I walking out of here with my chin
Held High
both of you guys though like have
parents that don't have a history of
like you know heart disease and cancer
right as do I so not only that but also
you exercise regularly and are the most
disciplined eaters I know except for
maybe Bateman but like
so if you guys aren't healthy nobody's
Health right like this is my I don't
know what was the last time you ate a
carbohydrate you
almost every meal I ate a sandwich
my liver and kidneys are going to be
terrible you might be right okay all
right let's keep going okay the next set
of metrics that they looked at were your
blood sugars so diabetes is what this
relates to so they did a like blood
glucose blood glucose and then they did
a hemoglobin A1c and I'll explain that
in a second but your glucose numbers
those random glucose numbers uh Glenn
you win again
yours was 65. that's that's you know 100
130 is like a normal range uh 65 82
78
99. oh no no can I ask you is that did
so I I I usually intermittent fast uh
almost every day I mean pretty much
every day
um and I it's my understanding that that
can help intermittent fasting is great
yeah I mean it's been around 200 years
it's really smart the hemoglobin A1c is
the metric that we now use to understand
if we're pre-diabetic that's really what
we want to know what these numbers or if
we're diabetic to see how bad our
diabetes is and whether we need to be
more aggressive with our treatment and
that number's a three-month average of
your blood sugar so it's not fasting
it's not two hours later
when I started practice it was a six
hour glucose tolerance test imagine
trying to stick somebody every hour six
times so the A1C hemoglobin is they they
take a hemoglobin molecule that's the
red blood cell right that carries the
oxygen through the system every cell in
the body is dependent on glucose is an
energy source so they take a bunch of
hemoglobin cells and they look at them
and they average the sugar content in
these cells and that's your A1C
hemoglobin so those numbers are if
normals
below 5.7 and here the decimal points
matter and you're a diabetic when you're
in the sevens you're pre-diabetic and
the sixes this is sort of a broad stroke
in Europe it's a whole different
measuring of these numbers I mean
between 5.7 and 6 like yeah no it's a
it's you start paying attention when
people are in in their sixes and is it
bad if you're a certain if you're too
low no it's good okay so too low is not
a bad thing okay that's good you all did
really well with your A1C so Charlie you
I'm still looking for a win here
good job you were 4.8
um only beaten by once again Glenn who
was 4.4 closely behind Megan was 5.0 and
Rob very acceptable 5.1 so these are
great numbers nice um and at this stage
in your life if you were really going to
be pre-diabetic these numbers would be a
little higher so you're probably I would
bet that there's not a lot of diabetes
in your family I don't think there's any
in mind I I don't know anybody I mean
there could be on that but not I don't
think there's any health issues in your
family based on where we are now you're
the unfortunately there's not a mental
health chart there yeah
well that's the next one yeah
the current score is Rob with two
Charlie has one Glenn has six and Meg
has four so the next
studies were the kidney functions and we
measure a protein that gets processed
through the kidney and if the kidney is
working normally that protein is
eliminated and if it's not eliminated in
these little filters in the kidney that
are responsible for getting rid of the
toxins are damaged or not working then
it backs up in the blood that creatinine
backs up in the blood and that number
goes higher so you want a low creatinine
it shows you that your kidneys are
working and you guys all did great but
who did the best normal's about up up to
1.2 and
Meg you have the wind here you had a
0.76 uh age very close second at 0.98
top man score
yes
and you're probably shot off a woman's
tea right so it doesn't really count
we're talking about a man's kidney here
all right I'll give you
you guys were close you were rob you
were one two six and Glenn you were one
two five but you're these are these are
all great numbers
um
so these filters are also measured in
something called the GFR and when you
see your lab stuff that's the filtration
rate of these little filters and so
in that regard the higher the number the
better we start to worry when those
numbers are below 40. you guys again did
very well the highest male number
at a at a 96. that's good you two tied
at 72 and the female winner
is 103. that's the overall but that's
the overall winner
we're not breaking this up we'll let her
give her the win I'll get a woman's
point for that so if you guys need a
kidney that's where you're going he's
the one okay you got two right you got
two stuff I do I do I think yeah hold on
yeah a set of liver tests were done
and so
um this one I'm gonna guess I don't know
it could be you we've all done I've done
the long term
I can tell you that
Charlie came in last okay all right
long-term damage yeah you all did fine
first
one they looked at was Billy Rubin it's
just one of these things that we have in
the kidney
um you're all in the normal range uh the
lower the bilirubin the better
glandular points oh wait a minute rob
you were 0.5 you were point six oh yo
Billy Rubin
I say we make another liquor like Scotch
yeah this was a photo finish on this one
okay
when you see people turn yellow it's
because their bilirubin is up and that
usually starts happening when they're in
the range of four
um I had jaundice when I was where am I
out of my Billy Roots you're one one
that's fine another photo finish for a
second you were one I saw that yeah and
watch that so so Rob gets the point yeah
that is astounding there's a globulin
which is just a different Protein that's
measured you guys were all in the normal
range who was the best and it was the
best who's the goblin who's got the best
goblins 2.1 for you guys
for 2.5 over here
um you don't want High globulins so then
by we'll share a point yes
[Music]
Glenn you take issue with having to
download a million apps now I'm the same
way but with getting a million
notifications now you know you can uh
you can turn those things off right oh I
do I silence everything except
[Music]
oh
oh that's the Shopify notification of a
new sale isn't it that's exactly right
Shopify makes it simple to sell to
anyone from anywhere whether your thing
is selling vintage t-shirts or recipes
for ghee and I love the dopamine Rush of
hearing I found another paying customer
another customer for what what are you
selling well don't worry about that
don't worry about that Charlie are you
selling ghee recipes you know because
why would you say that if you aren't you
know because it was oddly specific it's
uh probably at least key adjacent it's
absolutely an vicinity right that's what
I'm picking up
guys it's never been easier to sell and
grow my dream business which you don't
know what it is because I haven't really
talked that much about it um than it is
with Shopify and they're 24 7 support
and libraries of free educational
content help me feel in command of my
ghee Empire there it is yeah so whether
you want to sell ghee recipes and share
it with your friends or you want to be
super weird and secretive about it
either way sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com
Sunny all lowercase go to shopify.com
Sunny and start selling online today
shopify.com sunny get that key get that
key
[Music]
for all you listeners and creeps guess
what season is upon us that's right
spooky season and with spooky season
comes the latest scary soft Halloween
collection for me undies that fabric is
so soft and so live it actually does
kind of scare the [ __ ] out of me
sometimes because I feel like I put on
no underwear at all well if you want to
live out Glenn's Nightmare and discover
just how comfy these meat undies are
yourself you can get 20 off and free
shipping on your first purchase for
listening to this podcast yet no feeling
monster mashed up down there with this
stuff you know what I mean you know what
I'm talking about you're not so mashed
up on your monster and if you're a lazy
creep who Waits until the last minute to
get in the spirit and needs an 11th Hour
costume me undies has your back bone
with their spooky skeleton loungewear
set lazy bones the scary soft hype is
real everyone if you're not impressed
with me undies your first pair is on us
and that is a promise to get 20 off your
first order and free standard shipping
on us orders go to meet undies.com
that's meundies.com Sunny go creep it
out
[Music]
so the body needs iron to make red blood
cells and so there's two measures of
iron the first one is the actual iron
content a tie for second place 177.
Robin Charlie beat out by 82. and you
didn't have one oh oh it's different for
women though isn't it there's usually
lower because of menstruation correct
absolutely right wow so it's actually a
little unfair even if she did what he's
talking about all these years we've been
making fun of them and he knows you know
your iron you know you that's that's
exactly every time Dr kidford says
something Glenn's the nodding like you
know we kind of you can't touch it I
can't tell if you're making fun of me
I'm not
you're running away with them with the
man with the male title that one I
believe we're giving so iron are we
giving a point to Rob and Charlie then
do they go no no no no no no we're in
last place to be clear all right we're
tied for last
Glenn gets the Iron Point the Iron Point
Iron Man yeah but here is where Charlie
wins this is the PSA it's the prostate
antigen so as we get older our PSA goes
up uh goes up in cancer goes up and it
goes up as we age because the prostate
gland gets bigger it's just an enzyme
that the gland makes but if there's
activity in the gland
uh if you are
hypersexual or you change your sexual
pattern you're very sexual and then you
stop and then you start again those
transitions can raise the PSA so this
again is in context you have to look at
how this how this works also anybody
have a family history of prostate cancer
no yes but like very late in life okay
so that's not we don't we're not even
sure that's a cancer yeah at that point
we don't even treat those but
um the winner is I'm so happy to say
this Charlie 0.25
um and Robbie were 1.86 glad you were
0.37 so those are good numbers those are
all really good numbers it's all good
but the best butt number
how are you releasing all the pressure
in there yeah
okay yeah see I'm all over the place
maybe that's right yeah yeah yeah well
that is none of you had a bad number so
good numbers vitamins vitamin B9 which
is called folate
um again it's another B vitamin the B
vitamins are are important as we get
older the B vitamins get absorbed in one
very specific part of the small
intestine as we get older that
absorption site and the small intestine
and some people can wear out and so
people lose vitamin B as they get older
especially B12 and if you lose B12 you
get a lot of neurologic symptoms so
um you guys are young your vitamin
B levels are fine actually
the the B12 here are the numbers on the
B12 Glen do you supplement with with B
vitamin yeah I have to well I don't I
have the MTA uh the MTHFR
mutation so I don't I don't methylate
well uh so I have to take a methylation
supplement that includes uh B vitamins
and otherwise I don't like I can't get
it for my food so you're a little bit
above normal which is fine I mean you
know you know you're 11 69 when people
get into the 2000 Range and a lot of
people do because they ain't nothing but
B vitamins you got to put the brakes on
those people but you're fine and uh you
were all in a in a good range and there
is no advantage of having more or less
so there's really no winner in this
category but Charlie you were 392 Rob
896 and Meg you were three 434. so
you're all fine with your with I heard
you say no winner yes yeah does that
mean Glenn doesn't get a point for this
round then yeah because there's no
benefit to having more Glenn tell us
about this methylation and your off
casting or whatever
I was paying a lot more attention to his
health that is for sure well we've
always known that yeah it's some sort of
a genetic uh situation that I have that
uh
I don't fully totally understand it uh
you could probably explain it better
than I could but I just don't
um
you know uh I don't I'm not even totally
sure what methylating is but I don't
methylate certain vitamins and I know
folate is one of them right or
methylation is something that that the
body does in its metabolism to break
certain things down and
um there are different forms of this you
said you had a I've got two Snips yeah
two MTHFR Snips it actually has some it
actually has some relevance in pregnancy
yeah right and not going to happen at
this table but if you it's not going to
happen at that table either
that's been made abundantly Yeah by
choice unless it does happen then you'll
be forced to go through it so the
ability to hold on to a pregnancy if
you've got this genetic defect right how
did you figure how did you know to do
that who checked you noted to to check
for that yeah I mean I go see a
functional
medicine doctor and it's good you know
we do this kind of stuff all the time
yeah and then it's like a hobby to me
like I know that you know these guys are
giving me [ __ ] for it because they say
that I'm not I don't enjoy my life
because I I pay so much attention to
what I eat and stuff but the truth is
um I it's a it's a kind of a hobby for
me like I find I find to I don't know
eating a certain way and just trying to
dial in all the numbers and health and
stuff I just find it kind of interesting
it's an amazing machine that we have I
mean the way these things work on a
cellular level and on it's crazy to me
how all this stuff not only works but
integrates with everything else yeah so
it is it is fascinating and then how it
plays out in people's personalities
because you can have the same metrics
but you can have different
um you know different mental health
issues you can have different activity
levels you can so well then there's a
nature versus nurture aspect yeah that
too I would imagine or just the way
you're raised or your environment or
whatever it's gonna play along and now
as we're learning your gut biome is a
it's just a huge your gut biome is a
huge role is the role it's the king of
that yeah what's really fascinating so
the the the
microbiome is located between the small
intestine and the large intestine that's
where your appendix is so there's this
two inch little organelle called the
cecum in the cecum is where all these
bacterial colonies live and and they're
all predetermined Again by your genetics
by your epigenetics but the amount and
the relative values of these bacteria
viruses fungi they will dictate your
neurotransmitter levels which is what
happens in in controlling your behavior
they will
influence your immunity they will
influence they influence pretty much
everything that gets run through the
system and how the system runs so when
you take an antibiotic you're going to
distort the microbiome a little bit and
that's going to it may kill the bacteria
that's in your system but it's going to
also make the microbiome a little
unhappy so any any medicine that you
take is going to have some effect there
have they done any studies on whether
picturing a dog pooping will help you
poop better because we were talking
about that yeah what are the scientist
specific studies on like if you're
constipated and you want to use you know
imagery to sort of coax your doodoo out
of your out of your butthole uh
does picturing a dog pooping does that
does that uh I don't have to I like the
word doo-doo I haven't heard that yeah
that's good it's been a while since I
used it you should write a book I'm
going to write a book I think it would
affect you in some way I think it
depends on the person and the dog the
dog's imagination and yeah okay okay so
we've only got about 15 minutes left
with doctors
so he's
oh you're fine it's his time we'll move
out of the doo doo into the into the
bone marrow the bone marrow makes a red
blood cell a white blood cell and a
platelet the red cells carry oxygen the
white cells fight infection and the
platelets are the things that form scabs
when you cut yourself you guys were all
fine on all of this on the white blood
cells if you've got an A bacterial
infection that number would go up if you
got a viral infection those numbers go
down normals between four and ten you're
4.1 Charlie rob you were 7.3 again these
are all normal numbers Glenn you were
five seven and Meg you were seven one so
if you want the lower the lowest is
better
um in a in a setting like this I would
say the lowest is that because
that would potentially be an indicator
that his body is actually fighting less
pathogens negative pathogens and that's
why he's fighting more
well if his numbers are low if he was
fighting more virus yes it would lower
it oh but it's still in the normal range
right but it could be ridiculous
the red cell is interesting you got you
the three of you guys were so close and
so a red blood cell carries oxygen and a
non-smoking adult those numbers are
anywhere they're generally around 15. uh
you can see them up to 18 uh as smokers
tend to be in the higher range people
with big barrel chests have a higher
number wow
um
Charlie you were 16.7 rob you were 16.4
you were 16.0 and you were 14.0 so the
winner is oh so higher is better yeah
higher is better but Charlie Charlie Day
coming into it
blood cells are really good
I mean that's kind of everything when it
comes to health yeah yeah I mean if your
blood cells are bad you're like really
sick
you've got a you've got a good bone
marrow because you also won the platelet
race [ __ ] yeah so nice buddy buddy you
got good blood thanks man thanks man
thanks man thanks bro
hear that horse coming around the turn
it's three points yeah that's three
points seems a little unfair and so our
current health Point score is Rob with
four Charlie with five Glenn with eight
and Meg with six the electorates I'll go
through your all normal
um
sodium potassium and calcium and so
sodium and potassium for all you guys
who are normal 138 140 144 those are
perfectly normal numbers
you want to be higher or lower you you
were talking about being hydrated right
yeah so when you're when you're over
hydrated when too much that number goes
down because it dilutes down so you
actually need to hydrate a little bit
more
potassium again it's a normal range four
three three nine four two four one so
having a 3.9 potassium is not a bad
thing uh if it was below three five
there'd be some question and some issue
perhaps the higher is better
um the higher is better until you get
into the mid fives but that's not where
you are but it's it doesn't mean it's
better
does it but is it one of those things
like that other thing where it doesn't
it doesn't matter as long as you're
within a certain range or is there an
actual Advantage correct again context
let's say you were sick and your
potassium was low right and we have to
give you supplements of potassium and
then it comes higher well you're higher
because we gave it to you not because
that's your net these net these are
having a couple of these already and
what we've established is that Dr Kipper
has to pick whose potassium whose
potassium do you want that's the
ultimate so if I had to pick I would
pick now there is an acceptable an
acceptable answer would be any of them
you know what I'm just saying you don't
have I'm gonna have to go back and do
redo the other no I'm just saying yeah I
just wanted to play basketball
if it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if I had to pick a best potassium I
would if I wanted to design my own
potassium it would be like four and a
half you were 4.3 you were closest to
that okay so if I were to let's give
Charlie one thanks I get a banana plant
for the potassium good job Charlie
calcium last one and then we'll get to
the male stuff
um but look stop looking it gets already
competitive you guys were very close on
the calcium and it's not about high or
low but if we went for the higher score
um Charlie gets that one he was 10.1
well whose calcium level do you want
right let's continue to use that I'll
tell you who's calcium level I would
want I would want I would take all any
of these
um Rob and Glenn were 9-6 Megan was nine
five you were ten one
um
I'd probably take the 10-1
5
and the calcium
yeah you started stressing real strong
[Music]
okay peoples here at the Always Sunny
podcast you know we love doing things
with ease okay that's why we're glad our
friends at manscape they're joining us
for a fresh ball fall that's right fresh
ball is defined as the season of pumpkin
spice and making sure your crotch looks
nice it's great for when you want to sip
cider in an autumn breeze and trim your
balls with ease
right now are you are you trimming your
balls outdoors and in public in this
scenario it's unclear maybe you see
manscaped is is here to make sure that
your foliage isn't the only thing that's
uh shedding its excess leaves even
Mother Nature knows it's time to lose
that excess clutter I know when I use my
lawnmower 4.0 body hair trimmer from
their 10 part Platinum package I feel a
lot more in sync with the season the
moon you name it like a creature of the
forest in a werewolf perhaps like
something out of the Twilight movies
that's right yeah I'm I'm I'm constantly
uh comparing myself to the Twilight
movies yeah and you are actually look
basically I mean do you have a lot of
pubic hair and you need to get rid of it
use manscapes I mean it's a lot of
goblin good to try to you know just be
like look this stuff's gonna help you
trim your your peers right so you're
gonna get 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com when you use the code Sunny
manscape clear out the leaves it's your
tree trunks time to shine and in some
cases it's more of a drink than a trunk
[Music]
so recently we went on or and we blasted
our audience in the face with t-shirts
yeah get blasted but we only had two
t-shirt cannons and we would have been
able to blast way more faces with way
more shirts if we had another Canon
operator oh now that sounds like a job
for zip recruiter 4 out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
man ah
hiring it can be so tiring no well okay
yeah I mean I was just kidding with the
saying we don't have to sing a hole I've
been Desiring more more efficiencies
yeah yeah sort of okay okay so we're
going for it all right I get tired and
feeble trying to find the right people
was that good it was like you're saying
peephole I heard people yeah when you go
to
ziprecruiter.com Sunny try them for free
right now at ziprecruiter.com
[Music]
Megan you win the testosterone contest
I couldn't get that on your Labs yeah
they wouldn't do it Quest refused to
test my testosterone unless ordered by a
doctor
um you ain't a man I know they wouldn't
do it they wouldn't pick the order but
women make testosterone and we make
estrogen and testosterone ultimately
gets converted to estrogen so
um having said that the the the numbers
are good and now obviously this is going
to be the highest is the winner and that
would go to
Rob
the most manly at the table the most
masculine
testosterone age does matter
right because I'm a little younger age
matters when you that's a really great
question and to your point when you are
in your
early 50s
and Beyond those numbers start to come
down that's Nature's way of telling us
not to procreate and
um so yes I mean people
people do run out of steam as they get
older so what are we say these guys have
run out so let's hear these things
viewer 1131
Charlie 744
Glenn you were 26.
you were 7.93
well what was yours
7 47 44 11 31. this should count for so
many more pounds now hang on a second uh
I remember a year ago or so I just came
in just for a general physical in your
office and you had said hey your
testosterone is looking kind of low but
if you you feel energy you still have a
sex drive let's not do anything about it
has it gone up because I've done nothing
to get it up
I like that and it just keeps going up I
can't I can't respond to that
statement but so testosterone relates
only really to libido it doesn't when
you give people testosterone that are
low in testosterone they will say they
feel stronger they feel better they're
mentally more clear
there's never been any study that's
proven that and maybe there is truth to
that not everything has to be a study or
a database but as these one of the
reasons that you're careful with
supplementing testosterone is that if
you have a a brewing cancer in your
prostate that's just starting to develop
and you've take testosterone you're
pouring water on a flower it's it's just
gonna nurture it so we're very cautious
in prescribing testosterone so unless
someone was really complaining that they
had no sex drive and and
that's when you supplement but then you
have to watch their PSA really carefully
and if they had a family history of
prostate cancer you wouldn't supplement
well it's just another point on the
thing yeah yeah but it just kind of
makes me the most masculine well I'll
tell you we'll see how manly you take
it um are you guys ready to hear the
final scores yeah let's do it okay I
gotta pee real bad so
um in last place is Rob with Five Points
wow hard to believe could you repeat
back the
testosterone was just one uh
1131 yeah by the way thousands of
testosterone at this table that's them
on the couch it's completely useless
it's a good it's completely useless it's
a good metric I am in next place tied
with the amount of asterisks at six
points and then tied for first currently
are Charlie and Glenn tied at eight I
think the tie breaker should be your
blood pressure
I absolutely win we're having put zero
effort into any of this that's true that
should be a winner right now
living my life
I had five beers yesterday I'll tell you
what before we really start to jump on
each other
the big picture is that everyone's
numbers are good yeah oh and here's
healthy pretty healthy you're all very
healthy well for Vanity's sake I like to
get that BMI down a little bit but uh
yeah
I'm I'm happy that you guys are all
healthy yeah yeah yeah same I mean I got
spooked when I got a call from the blood
company about the cholesterol I was like
well I'm I'm done
but you're saying it's good I'm saying
it's good okay great I still got the
blood pressure is high on all of us
that's fast
we're gonna see how do you want your
pressure taken yes please okay let's do
it let's get the actual blood pressure
taken what do you mean right now he's
gonna test your
your blood pressure properly and then
let's do all that's going to be the time
to come up with a bunch of different
tests and do those two this is fun
I ran four miles today did you okay
there's another metric you know what I
mean yeah but it's like it's good for
you you don't have the stress of the
competition rotting on this
you know what I mean yeah right low
slower Stakes for me yeah he's trying to
make it a mistake but it's not I don't
need to prove anything I know that was
not with 1100 testosterone let's fall
asleep
but I applaud you Glenn for taking good
care of yourself I mean it's very few
people do that you're the kind of guy I
don't see in my office because you're
healthy right right right right
I was healthy as Charlie though no
it's a local Street 67 blood pressures
are very much the same you're 123.
over 78 you were 122 I think yeah
that's pretty good it's way better than
last time let's do Glenn now this is the
one that matters if you can beat
123 over 78
or a pulse of 67. this is exciting it's
not that's not that exciting it's
inside
relax very relaxed
he's standing over the pot it's a nice
even stroke
it's headed towards the hole and 1 30 83
over 83.74 pulse I'm sorry that's not
gonna be enough to beat Charlie
Charlie is your 2020
Hills I am so relieved
this is a normal book yes it's a normal
blood pressure but it's not the best
blood pressure
I believe I had the best blood pressure
but it's not about me it's about our
champion
at the podcast Mr Charlie Day
[Applause]
[Music]
this is why you're my doctor oh yeah
well put an asterisk on with a whole
thing for sure okay I'll tell you what
I'm hugely relieved because we did the
blood I just I I haven't been working
out as much I was like out I've let it
slide and then uh you know I get the
call from the people and they're like
the cholesterol is high I'm like I knew
it this it's it's happening
um buddy I put you at number one I said
it was gonna be you a tie between you
and Megan and I was wrong
that's all Tom and Mary day yeah well I
want to thank you so much for joining us
thank you
to get you out so you can go help other
people with non-podcast
competitions
uh that was a pleasure a round of
applause
thank you
thank you Sandra awesome and I love that
you have like an old school yeah doctor
bad yeah yeah like the 1860s is that a
prop
[Music]
[Applause]